und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber in
deutschland gibt es keine impfpflicht
sagt die kanzlerin es gibt einen aufruf
zur impfung
guten abend bei der beurteilung der
aktuellen lage ist außerdem die inzidenz
die zahl der neuen corona ansteckungen
nicht mehr allein entscheidend aber das
ist nicht neu steht seit märz schon im
infektionsschutzgesetz die frage ist was
politik jetzt daraus macht im wahlkampf
und im dreieck zwischen impfung
freiheitsbeschränkung und risiko
eingehen die faktenlage von christian
von rechenberg
da stehen sie also 3 gegen korona soll
das bild wohl vermitteln die kanzlerin
bringt das gewicht ihres amtes mit heute
beim besuch des rk ii mit dem
gesundheitsminister 3 für ein thema für
einen aufruf leute lasst euch in die
dritte welle ist ja nicht gebrochen
worden weil wir alles so fallen im griff
hatten sondern dass sie so schnell
gebrochen wurde und so entschieden und
dass wir auch bei instanzen jetzt im
besten falle unter fünf jahren
das war nur der tatsache geschuldet dass
sich das impfen bemerkbar gemacht hat
die inzidenz das maß aller maßnahmen
sinkt seit april von knapp 170 auf unter
von fliegt heute nach leichtem anstieg
bei 6,5 und jetzt incidents ade die
bundes notbremse und ihre onlinepräsenz
hunderte inzidenz ist schon geschichte
das entsprechende gesetz ausgelaufen
übernehmen nun also andere parameter wie
medien schon dunkeln
sagen wir mal so ein klein wenig sollen
sie die inzidenz bleibt nach wie vor
eine wichtige größe wahl aus ihr vieh je
nach impfstoff wiederum folgt man kann
nicht zu einer überlastung des
gesundheitssystems proben man kann heute
mit höheren instanzen
leben ohne dass das gesundheitssystem
überfordert wird bei gut 43 prozent
vollständig geimpften kommt die inzidenz
also an ihre grenzen
sie bleibt bestandteil von
landesgesetzen und handlungsempfehlungen
benötigt jedoch beistand wenn wir nur
mit der sogenannten inzidenz arbeiten
sehen wir eben nicht die konsequenz also
ein pc positiver test allein reicht
nicht aus wir müssen wissen wer wird
krank wie viele werden krank und so
dürfte die zahl der korona bedingten
krankenhaus einlieferungen künftig mehr
gewicht erhalten
von dort gibt es tendenziell gute
nachrichten nur noch 405 schwere corona
fälle landesweit es sind die patienten
aus der dritten welle die dort noch
immer in behandlung sind
das sind hauptsächlich patienten
zwischen den dreißigsten und sechzigsten
lebensjahr die wir jetzt noch versorgen
vielleicht einige über 60 aber die bahn
alle oder in der regel nicht gewiss es
gibt einzelfälle wo auch schon eine in
pfungstadt 100 aber das sind wirklich
einzelfälle wo sich die menschen
infizieren schwer zu sagen laut letzten
bericht des lkw handelt es sich in den
meisten kreisen um ein diffuses
geschehen mit zahlreichen häufungen in
privathaushalten aber auch im
beruflichen umfeld sowie im
freizeitbereich in gefahr ist eben jener
altersgruppe die auch in den kliniken
liegt insbesondere sind glaube ich jetzt
die 30 bis 60 jährigen gefährdet schwer
krank zu werden auch wenn die delta
variante nicht so häufig einen schweren
verlauf induziert wir haben immer noch
millionen von bürgern bürger die nicht
geimpft sind von den notwendigen 85%
impfquote ist diese gruppe noch zu weit
entfernt auch diese nachricht
hinterließen sie heute in berlin und
eine absage im pflicht wird es in
deutschland nicht geben
als im mai die inzidenz erst unter 100
und dann unter 50 fielen hatte die
bundeswehr
das bedeutet die länderregierungen haben
wieder die verantwortung für die
pandemie bekämpfung übernommen bayerns
minister klaus holetschek ist zurzeit
vorsitzender der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz einen
schönen guten abend
guten abend erklären wenn die inzidenz
nicht mehr der maßstab ist haben sie
dann überhaupt noch einen klaren maßstab
ich denke die inzidenz ist immer noch
wichtig als vorwand system aber
natürlich ist es gut wenn wir das thema
des impfens jetzt berücksichtigen und
vielleicht auch die hospitalisierung
rate mit einbeziehen und deshalb
gemeinsam gewichten und das sozusagen
ein neues leitbild dann auch wird aber
das ist nichts was jetzt unsere
zuschauer und wir sofort messen können
an dem was morgens in den nachrichten
gemeldet wird das waren klare maßstäbe
und jetzt wird das alles so ein bisschen
verschwurbelt die inzidenz wird bleiben
aber ich glaube es ist doch richtig und
wichtig jetzt den maßstab auch zu setzen
wie hoch ist die impfquote wie schlägt
sich das in der belegung der
krankenhausbetten nieder
und das müssen wir jetzt gewichten und
zu einem einfachen faktor zusammenführen
glaube ich damit es genauso draußen noch
ankommt und verstanden wird
aber noch können sie uns nicht sagen was
dieser faktor dann ist zusammengerechnet
ich denke das rk ii ist da jetzt
gefordert weil wir eine
bundeseinheitliche lösung auch zu diesem
thema brauchen aber klar ist die instanz
als vorwand wert wird ein wichtiges
thema bleiben und die krankenhaus
belegung das war ja immer schon ein
thema auch was intensivbetten angeht
wird noch mehr an bedeutung gewinnen was
die krankheitsverläufe betrifft
nun hat die bundeskanzlerin heute in
übereinstimmung mit dem rk ii gesagt wir
müssen 85 prozent bei den unter
60-jährigen erreichen und 90% impfungen
bei den über 60-jährigen wird bayern das
in absehbarer zeit schaffen wir werden
uns alle mühe geben es ein sehr
ehrgeiziges ziel aber wir wollen jetzt
noch mal vollgas geben niedrigschwellige
angebote auf den weg bringen
zusammen mit kooperationspartnern aus
den vereinen hotel und gastronomie viele
die sich jetzt engagieren und noch mal
alles geben damit wir möglichst vielen
menschen eine impfung verabreichen
können
nun ist aber das kogit virus immer noch
da und immer noch gefährlich und das
gelten merkwürdigerweise
unterschiedliche maßstäbe
in nordrhein westfalen bedeutet eine
inzidenz von unter 10 fast unbeschränkte
freiheit für die bürger in bayern
bedeutet sie weiterhin einschränkungen
hat nordrhein-westfalen liebe revieren
als bayern
das glaube ich sicherlich nicht aber bei
uns ist das thema der umsicht und
vorsicht von anfang an ein wichtiger
maßstab gewesen und dem wollen wir auch
weiter folgen
nun ist das eher eine spannende zeit in
der dieses vergleichs rennen läuft man
will als politiker am wahltag ende
september weder als derjenige dastehen
der zu leichtsinnig war bei eröffnungen
weil will aber auch nicht als der
dastehen der unsinnigerweise die bürger
weiter beschränkt und eingesperrt hat wo
es auch im nachbarland eigentlich viel
besser gegangen
ich denke das thema ist wie können wir
die menschen am besten schützen und das
muss der maßstab sein
dann müssen wir die einzelnen maßnahmen
immer auf ihre verhältnismäßigkeit
prüfen und das müssen wir permanent auch
tun die pandemie stellt uns immer wieder
vor neue herausforderungen
das haben wir auch gelernt die data
variante ist wieder eine neue
herausforderung für uns aber wichtig ist
jetzt tatsächlich dass wir möglichst
schnell mit dem impfen noch vorankommen
ich habe noch eine frage an den
christlich soziale union
gesundheitsminister wir werden im lauf
der sendung noch berichten über die lage
in der welt wo vor allen dingen in
afrika die impf situation katastrophal
ist ist es moralisch vertretbar dass man
in deutschland anfängt über
auffrischungsimpfungen oder ergänzungs
impfungen im herbst nachzudenken
während in afrika impfstoffe dringend
gebraucht werden und kaum ein prozent
der bevölkerung geimpft ist also was
wirklich wichtig ist dass bei uns kein
impfstoff verworfen wird der woanders
gebraucht wird das haben wir auch noch
mal sehr deutlich gemacht es darf kein
impfstoff verfallen der woanders noch
sinnvoll eingesetzt werden kann
auf der anderen seite haben wir
natürlich eine verantwortung auch für
die variable und gruppen und muss sich
ständig überprüfen lässt die
immunantwort nach brauchen wir neue
impfungen das ist genau dieser grad der
abwägung die wir immer wieder treffen
müssen
sie haben auf eine schwierige frage mit
dem grunde mit einer
selbstverständlichkeit geantwortet dass
wir nicht impfstoff auf den müll
schmeißen können während der bau anders
dringend gebraucht wird
die frage war eine frage der
priorisierung geht perfekter schutz in
europa vor einem minimalen notfallschutz
in afrika wir haben ja eine
verantwortung glaube ich der wir
gemeinsam gerecht werden europa wird
sich engagieren für impfstoffdosen in
der dritten welt und in anderen
bereichen das ist richtig und wichtig
auf der anderen seite müssen wir auch
der verantwortung für die bürgerinnen
und bürger in unserem land gerecht
werden
die antwort des politikers und ministers
dankeschön und einen guten abend
dieses gespräch haben wir so ungefähr um
viertel nach acht geführt nachrichten
nun von gundula gause
der 20-jährige afghanistan-einsatz der
bundeswehr soll nun doch mit einem
großen zapfenstreich vor dem reichstag
am 31 august gewürdigt werden
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer kündigte ein
gesamtstaatliches gedenken an auch um
die 59 deutschen soldaten zu ihren die
bei dem einsatz in afghanistan ihr leben
verloren haben
am niederrhein hatte die
verteidigungsministerin ein feld raum
kommando der bundeswehr in dienst
gestellt als teil militärische
aufklärung sollen von dort aus
satelliten geschützt und überwacht und
gefährlicher weltraumschrott beobachtet
werden
sinti und roma werden in deutschland
weiterhin diskriminiert als konsequenz
entsprechende ergebnisse einer
unabhängigen kommission setzt sich
bundesinnenminister seehofer für einen
staatsvertrag mit der minderheit ein
es gehe um respekt und anerkennung der
vorsitzende des zentralrats der sinti
und roma rose kritisierte es gebe zu
wenig instrumente für den kampf gegen
diskriminierung in schulen oder beim
kontakt mit behörden in kuba sind nach
den größten anti regierungs protesten
seit jahrzehnten mindestens 100 menschen
verhaftet worden
bürgerrechtler berichten auch von
exzessiver gewalt gegen demonstranten
und auch von internetblockaden tausende
hatten gegen mangelwirtschaft und
unterdrückung durch die sozialistische
regierung protestiert kubas präsident
kündigte an künftige demonstrationen
niederzuschlagen us-präsident beiden
lobte den mut der demonstranten und
sicherte ihnen unterstützung zu bei
einem großbrand in einem südlichen
krankenhaus sind 92 menschen ums leben
gekommen dutzende wurden verletzt
das feuer war auf einer
isolationsstation für privatpatienten
ausgebrochen
vermutet wird dass eine explodierte
sauerstoffflasche den brand verursacht
haben könnte
angehörige der brandopfer beklagen das
missmanagement der behörden die
irakische regierung suspendierte
verantwortliche und ordnete festnahmen
an
in südafrika ist die zahl der todesopfer
bei den gewalttätigen ausschreitungen
nach der inhaftierung von ex präsident
zuma auf mindestens 45 gestiegen
elf menschen kamen in einem
einkaufszentrum ums leben
dort war es bei plünderungen laut
polizei zu einer massenpanik gekommen
die ausschreitungen dauern den fünften
tag in folge an
die regierung hat 2500 soldaten in die
unruheregion in johannesburg entsandt
hunderte menschen wurden festgenommen
während die länder des reichen nordens
immerhin hoffen dürfen dass die sperre
wand aus vorsichtsmaßnahmen hightech
medizin und impfungen
das virus eindämmen rollt zum beispiel
auf afrika eine dritte welle zu der die
regierungen und gesellschaften dort
nichts entgegenzusetzen haben
im quoten liegen dort zum großen teil
bei etwa einem prozent
ein team des zdf ist unterwegs in der
zentralafrikanischen republik die
prioritäten gruppe nummer eins beginnt
dort bei 51 jahren eine höhere grenze
wäre sinnlos die durchschnittliche
lebenserwartung liegt in dem land kaum
darüber bei 53 die niedrigste
lebenserwartung der welt
peter theißen bericht
wochenlang hat giulia turri auf diesen
tag gewartet heute endlich bekommt sie
am krankenhaus von boss mb ihre erste
impfung gegen korona bisher tut es nicht
weh
mal sehen wie es später aussieht bei den
meisten macht sich grosse erleichterung
breit nach der spritze ich habe schon
leute sterben sehen ankurbelt die
krankheit ist realität
ein glückstag für 22 menschen denn so
viele dosen astrazeneca impfstoff sind
heute eingetroffen ein paar tropfen auf
den heißen stein der
zentralafrikanischen republik für das
gesamte land gab es bislang gerade mal
80 1000 impfdosen aus dem kovacs
programm der korona beauftragte der
regierung fordert die freigabe der impf
patente
das wäre sehr nützlich das wissen sollte
allen ländern und auch der bevölkerung
zentralafrikas zugänglich sein
am krankenhaus von boss mb arbeitet
gerade eine deutsche ärztin für ein
halbes jahr sie impft auch gegen korona
allerdings viel gefährlicher grassierten
hier andere krankheiten
[Musik]
das durchschnittsalter der bevölkerung
ist ja auch anders weit mehr als corona
bedroht auch der bürgerkrieg die
menschen anfang des jahres rückten
rebellen nach boss mb vor
sie hinterließen eine spur der
verwüstung viele einwohner flohen in den
busch wochenlang harte familie in der
wildnis aus es war schrecklich dort wir
lebten in ständiger angst vor wilden
tieren und schlangen die uns weisen
könnten wie zigtausende andere
geflüchtete zentralafrikaner konnte
gaspar reinmann york fällt nicht
bestellen es ist zugewuchert mit unkraut
in teilen des landes droht nun eine
hungersnot probleme die korona gerade in
den schatten stellen
trotzdem sagen gesundheitsexperten die
gefahr durch das virus sollte auch in
zentralafrika nicht unterschätzt werden
schließlich könnten auch hier neue
varianten entstehen allein es fehlt der
impfstoff den photomatix auf der ganzen
welt bekannt wir wären bereit im land
hier gibt's gute im team
es gab keine große kinderlähmung
kampagne bis vor zwei jahren also diese
teams sind alle bereit
es ist nichts da
in bussen gelesen die 22 impfdosen
schnell in den armen bis zur nächsten
lieferung könnte es noch viele wochen
dauern
wir sprachen darüber schon vorhin mit
minister holetschek was folgt aus der
christlichen oder einfach der
menschlichen verpflichtung zu helfen
darf deutschland an die eigenen bürger
denken bis hier der letzte kräftig
gesunde jugendliche vollständig geimpft
ist bevor die erste impfdosis von ihr
nach afrika geht es ziemlich leichte
marktwirtschaftliche antwort wäre die
frage vermeiden einfach mehr produzieren
und schneller und auf der ganzen welt
und auch in fabriken die das patent für
den impfstoff nicht haben die kriegen
dann einfach das rezept angela merkel
wird übermorgen in washington auf einen
joe biden treffen der das gut finde
die kanzlerin sieht das anders und hat
offenbar ihren spd-außenminister
einigermaßen auf ihre linie gebracht
bevor der heute in die usa nach michigan
flog andreas köhlers berichtet das land
dem amerika und dem die halbe welt
blockade vorwirft heißt deutschland der
druck wächst nicht nur in washington das
blockade land muss etwas tun
in detroit fährt am mittag der deutsche
außenminister vor die impfstoff fabrik
von kaiser und versucht nicht wie ein
blockierer zu klingen maß erklärt sich
bereit über das teilen der impfstoff
lizenzen zu reden aber wir werden ja
selbst wenn die impfstoffe lizenzen
freigegeben würden
produktionskapazitäten brauchen
zusätzliche und deshalb ist das für mich
das prioritäre thema zumindest im moment
der druck auf deutschland wächst weil
die not wächst und die spaltung der welt
in impfstoff reich und impfstoff bahn in
pakistan impfquote 1,8 prozent
blockieren hunderte die straße vor einem
impfzentrum sie haben tage und nächte
gewartet vergeblich
in indonesien impfquote 5,5 prozent ist
die zahl der beerdigungen so hoch dass
für abschied für trauer kaum zeit bleibt
in tunesien impfquote 5,3 prozent
verzweifelt diese tochter weil ihre
schwer kranke mutter kein bett bekommt
dabei gibt es ein bett sagt sie aber da
liegt ein toter drin
es ist höchste zeit dass europa seine
impfstoff fertigung öffnet damit auch
wir impfstoff kaufen können wir bitten
nicht um spenden das geld haben wir die
usa frankreich die mehrheit der
industrienationen wäre bereit die
impfstoffhersteller zur herausgabe ihrer
patente zu zwingen
es ist vor allem der widerstand merkels
der einen vorstoss der g7 verhindert
deutschland ist der zweitgrößte
impfstoff spender der welt zahlt an
hilfs kampagnen wie kovacs mehr als zwei
milliarden euro
das produkt teilen ja die formel 1 denn
so wie wir heute schnellstmöglich
impfstoffe für alle weltweit brauchen so
werden wir auch in zukunft weiter darauf
angewiesen sein dass impfstoffe
entwickelt werden
das wird nur gelingen wenn der schutz
geistigen eigentums nicht außer kraft
gesetzt wird sondern gewahrt bleibt mir
ja genommen gefragt da geht ja wir geben
zu dass es wichtig ist die impfstoff
hersteller für ihre investitionen und
ihre forschung auch mit geld zu belohnen
aber wenn sie die patente nicht
freigeben und die ganze welt stirbt was
haben sie dann davon
die idee statt impfstoff die
impfstoffproduktion zu verschenken ist
überaus populär aber auch überaus
schlecht sagt die impfstoff entwicklerin
unser herstellungsprozess besteht aus
mehr als 50.000 schritten jeder einzelne
muss ganz präzise ausgeführt werden
damit unser vakzin wirksam ist und
sicher deutschland schlägt vor nicht
patente verschenken sondern lizenzen
vergeben deutschland wird weiter als
blockierer gelten
die bundesregierung kann mit ersten
geldern aus dem eu corona aufbau von
rechnen
die eu finanzminister haben die pläne
von 12 eu-staaten zur bewältigung der
pandemie folgen angenommen und mit den
deutschland zugesprochenen zuschüssen in
höhe von 25,6 milliarden euro soll im
klimaschutz und digitalisierung
investiert werden
insgesamt hat die eu in der korona krise
750 milliarden euro schulden aufgenommen
hauptprofiteure sind spanien und italien
angesichts verschärfter klimaziele
rechnet die bundesregierung mit einem
höheren strombedarf bis 2030 werde der
verbrauch bis zu 15 prozent höher sein
als bislang angenommen sagte
wirtschaftsminister altmaier grund sei
auch der beschleunigte ausbau der e
mobilität valerie passend dazu die
meldung von volkswagen zur neuen
konzernstrategie richtung
elektrofahrzeuge ja und die alte
strategie soll dabei helfen die neue zu
finanzieren denn vorher ist verdient vw
noch das meiste geld mit seinen
verbrennen
sie sollen den umstieg auf e autos
mitfinanzieren mit blick auf schärfere
klimaziele will der konzern seinen co2
abdruck deutlich verkleinern
vw stellt auf e fahrzeuge um und zwar
schneller als gedacht volkswagen macht
tempo bis 2030 soll die hälfte der vw
modelle batteriebetrieben sein
zehn jahre später sollen dann fast alle
neuen fahrzeuge der hauptmarken
emissionsfrei fahren
knackpunkt beim ausbau der e mobilität
werden immer mehr die batterien sie von
zulieferern an zu kaufen ist teuer
vw baut daher wie andere autobauer auch
nun eigene fabriken
eine davon soll auf jeden fall in
deutschland entstehen im
niedersächsischen salzgitter
fünf weitere in europa verteilt
kostenpunkt 15 bis 20 milliarden euro
fertigstellung bis 20 30 volkswagen hat
das ehrgeizige ziel ganz vorn dabei zu
sein bei der e-mobilität vor allem gegen
den wettbewerber tesla aufzuholen aber
vw ist keine ausnahme
auch opel daimler general motors ford
alle bekennen sich zur e mobilität der
verbrenner scheint ein auslaufmodell zu
werden
vielen dank valerie überraschend hat
opel-chef loschelder seinen rückzug bis
ende august bekannt gegeben
gerade noch hatte der 52-jährige die
traditionsmarke auf eine rein
elektrische zukunft eingestellt und
zuvor den autobauer wieder profitabel
gemacht jetzt verlässt er opel auf
eigenen wunsch nachfolger soll uwe hoch
geschätzt werden bislang deutschland
chef von renault
der deutsche wetterdienst warnt
weiterhin vor extrem ergiebigem
dauerregen bis donnerstag früh vor allem
im westen
außerdem ist auch in der mitte
deutschlands mit schweren gewittern
starkregen und sturmböen zu rechnen
in baden württemberg sind bereits
kleinere flüsse über die ufer getreten
hochwasser der elsenz setzte in eppingen
das gelände der landesgartenschau unter
wasser und auch die wasserstände der
großen flüsse sind schon deutlich erhöht
wie hier am rhein
dagegen hält die hitzewelle im westen
der usa an schwächt sich zwar etwas ab
aber die waldbrände breiteten sich bei
anhaltender trockenheit dort weiter aus
auch der berühmte yosemite nationalpark
ist bedroht noch sind die feuer 30
kilometer entfernt im norden
kaliforniens sind mittlerweile hunderte
quadratkilometer wald und buschland
zerstört ebenso wie dutzende häuser
die us behörden zählen in zehn
bundesstaaten von alaska bis wyoming
fast 60 waldbrände tausende anwohner
mussten sich in sicherheit bringen
die filmfestspiele in cannes dieses jahr
sind wie ein dammbruch
nicht wegen des wetters sondern wegen
des rückstaus an filmen in anderthalb
jahren pandemie die sich jetzt
massenhaft bahn brechen in die
wettbewerb
aber auf den markt und in die kinos im
großen strom rollen nuggets von gold wie
der neue film des zauber regisseurs wes
anderson den er jetzt ein ganzes jahr
zurückgehalten hat und der von einer
ausgehungerten kritik weltweit gefeiert
wird auch unsere sabine schulz hat er
kritisch gefallen es ist der auftritt
auf den kann seit einem jahr wartet wes
anderson und sein all star aus sonnen
der mann ist kult und hat seine ganz
eigene handschrift schräg knallbunt
unverkennbar und alle wollen dabei sein
will mary tilda swinton adrian brody
wilson und das ist nur die kann
delegation die liste großer namen nimmt
kein ende
[Musik]
in der print dispatch geht es um einen
amerikanischen journalisten der in
frankreich der 50er 60er jahre eine
zeitung gründet damit er schreiben kann
was er will
es begann als ein urlaub und begierig
der strahlenden zukunft in kansas zu
entkommen verwandelte avz juni die reihe
seiner reisebericht kolumnen in the
french dispatch einen wöchentlichen
tatsachenbericht zu den themen
weltpolitik kunst hohe und niedere und
breit gefächerte alltagsgeschichten ist
dass mich ein bisschen zu halbzeiten
diesmal bin ich nicht viele anständige
leute sollten verband sei charmant ist
auch bill berry und überlässt mit den
platz an seiner seite weil till das
finden sich zum interview verspätet hat
ich denke der film ist eine hommage an
den journalismus an alle journalisten
aber für den regisseur ist es auch ein
mittel seine geschichte zu erzählen die
sehr von dem berühmten new yorker
magazin inspiriert ist und von seinen
autoren
es heißt was ein bisschen habe bereits
auf der schulbank mehr im new yorker
gelesen als sie den schulbüchern und so
ist auch der new yorker mekka sind
gründer rick ross vorbild für wilburys
rolle
er stellte aus den besten exil
journalistin seinerzeit ein team
zusammen das waren seine leute gerade
jetzt ist es wichtig daran zu erinnern
wie sehr wir auf leidenschaftlichen
journalismus angewiesen sind auf die
unstillbare neugier darauf müssen wir
setzen
[Musik]
thema des heutigen vortragsabend mit dem
börsentag
gewiss die lauteste künstlerische stimme
seiner rauflustigen generation
ob kunstszene oder politik skurrile
stories aus den zeitungsseiten zum leben
erweckt des künstlers mose entpuppt sich
als gefängniswärter in ein feuerwerk an
fantasie und originellen bild tableaus
nur leider ziemlich überfrachtet
mitunter bitte zuschauer erschlagen
was bleibt ist herrlich detailreiche
retro schrulligkeit und satirischer
wortwitz
eine stunde bis zum druck du bist
gefeuert wirklich in meinem büro wird
nicht geweint
auch wenn sein film in cannes die
geister ein wenig bald tosende applaus
für bis anderson und sowohl
verwechselbaren film universum in
deutschen kinos erst ende oktober für
viele paare und erst recht für
alleinstehende gibt es nur einen weg
sich in kinderwunsch zu erfüllen die
samenspende in deutschland schon lange
legal aber vor allem in den 80er jahren
eine sache die so ein bisschen
verdruckst und insgeheim blieb was
bedeutet das für kinder wenn sie davon
erfahren wie geht es ihnen mit ihrer
mühevollen suche nach eigenen wurzeln
und wie ist das wenn man mit dem
gedanken fertig werden muss dass der
biologische vater gar nicht vater sein
sondern sie vielleicht nur ein paar
markt verdienen wollte ist nichts böses
aber eben auch nichts liebevolles und
das beschäftigt die 37° -reportage
gleich nach dem wetter und nachrichten
gibt es dann wieder um mitternacht in
unserem heute schon mal update mit nasa
aktivieren
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren der
dauerregen im westen ist das eine aber
noch viel interessanter aktuell sind die
kräftigen gewitter die haben sich heute
nachmittag über der schweiz und über
österreich gebildet sind dann weiter
nach norden gezogen und jetzt gewittert
es hier ganz kräftig in sachsen
thüringen und auch im norden bayerns da
sind zum teil in kaum einer stunde 80
liter regen pro quadratmeter zusammen
gekommen schauen wir uns an wo die
gewitter jetzt aktuell liegen wie sie
weiterziehen
sie sehen die werden jetzt auch bald
niedersachsen erreichen und auch das
südliche sachsen anhalt sowie der
südliche brandenburg
es bleibt also sehr ungemütlich in
dieser nacht es gibt weitere heftige
gewitter mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen
etwas ruhiger wird die nacht hier in
bayern seien da sind die gilt ja
weggezogen und direkt an der see wenn
die gewitter auf die nordsee ausziehen
die temperaturen heute nach sind ganz
unterschiedlich es bleibt sehr mild in
der nordhälfte mit temperaturen von 20
bis 18 grad deutlich kühler wird die
nach dem südwesten mit 13 bis 10 grad
und morgen über tag erwarten uns dann
höchstwerte bis 30 grad im nordosten
ganz anders sieht das im südwesten
deutschlands aus nicht nur so 18 bis 21
grad und morgen erwartet uns kräftiger
dauerregen und die kräftigsten
regenfälle die gibt es hier wohl so vom
westlichen niedersachsen bis zum
schwarzwald
es können allein an dem tag morgen 80
liter pro quadratmeter noch mal
zusammenkommen im osten gibt es dazu
kräftige gewitter und mit gewittern
haben wir es dann auch noch am
donnerstag und freitag zu tun
erst am samstag beruhigt sich die lage
guten abend